la compagnie air france pratiquement
paralysé demain par une grève de 24
heures seuls 14 vols sur la centaine
prévus seront assurés c'est une drôle de
grève puisque l'ensemble des syndicats
d'air france proteste contre la
concurrence des chartes heures qui ont
maintenant le droit de desservir les
antilles et la réunion
explication jean marc dubois et
dominique meurs demain ce ne sera pas la
peine de regarder dans ses jumelles
les avions d'air france ne décolleront
pas ils resteront au hangar la raison de
cette grève c'est l'autorisation
accordée à deux compagnies privées
pointe et remy nerfs de desservir les
antilles et la réunion avec une période
de trois ans pour remplir un cahier des
charges de service public comme par
exemple des tarifs pas 50 % pour les
moins de 12 ans pour les syndicats d'air
france ces compagnies ne respecteront
pas les règles du jeu
si on n'impose pas son nombre de règles
identiques à tout le monde au départ bd
mais l'évidence d'un quatre ans les
habitudes qui seront prises sera
difficile d'y revenir
est ce que vous pensez de cette période
de 3 ans ne sera pas respectée non par
un 3 ans et compagnie vont faire ce
qu'elles veulent la compagnie el
nacional air france aura à supporter les
conséquences du service public ça veut
dire ça veut dire ça veut dire perdre de
l'argent à certains moments de l'année
et nous disons qu il appartient à l'état
de compenser pour les deux compagnies
privées pointer et minerve
il s'agit là d'un procès d'intention
elle estime qu'air france a peur de leur
concurrence la france n'aime pas perdre
son monopole sur les anti monopole
qu'elle a depuis
depuis au moins 40 ans et évidemment il
n'est jamais agréable pour une
entreprise de perdre le monopole qui lui
a pendant des années donner des
privilèges
le gouvernement lui a promis de faire
respecter ce cahier des charges
notamment pour tout ce qui concerne les
problèmes de sécurité
alors affaire à suivre et attention donc
de masse et vous devez prendre un vol
d'air france il n'y aura fort peu alors
si vous souhaitez avoir des informations
vous pouvez appeler dès ce soir
le 45 35 61 61
et si vous habitez paris puis si vous
résidez en province vous devez appeler
le 43 20 15 55 43 20 15 50